our next guest is a grammy award-winning
legendary music icon whose contributions
to art and music
and culture span decades thanks to her
we've been on our feet and catching the
rhythm and doing the conga
for the last 40 years please welcome the
glorious
gloria estefan oh
my gosh oh my god production
and i'm a huge fan of yours drew by the
way hello
we are i love you so much and by the way
you look
so beautiful oh thank you so much
what a privilege to be on your show
there's so much to celebrate we're
having a hard time figuring out like
which subject to prioritize of your
incredibly multi-diverse life
one of the things was that you had said
um
i believe that your 40s were one of your
favorite decades
yes absolutely you know when people say
oh no i'm turning 40.
especially women okay i tell them that's
my favorite decade it was
you're you know you're still hot you're
you're my body was on point i would
because i had been working out so much
after that accident too
and i got a little miracle when i was 37
that they had told me i'd never be able
to have another baby
and i had my daughter emily so it was
the best years of my life
actually took time off from touring um
to be able to go to her games because
she was an amazing basketball player
starting in fifth grade
and she was a musician and i would go to
all her shows
and take her to school we took her to
school every day emilia and i and
i picked her up so i really i had the
luxury at that time
to be able to really choose what i
wanted to do but yeah
40s were magnificent every every
decade's been great because i i always
say
you're either older or dead so i'll take
whatever comes with it
the reason i love hearing you talk about
your 40s
with you know a beautiful reverie and
positivity
is i'm smack dab in the middle of them
right now
and this decade without question has
been the best of my life
and i'm glad that we were able to have
these life paths where we could focus on
work
and then take time off when we had our
kids
um and that's such a blessing and it's
it is a
luxury it's a luxury and
not many women can take their kids to
work which i did
because i was on tour all over the world
and uh
when emily was two we went on tour with
my then 16 year old son
and her at two and they'd see their mom
bigger than life on that stage and then
want to spend time after then i became
mommy after the show
and it's a great grounding and beautiful
experience and i wouldn't have had it
any other way
oh my god talking to you is such an
inspiration and
your husband emilio you guys married in
1978
yes indeed we've been married 42 years
45 together the first one he was my boss
yeah it's been great i
i am a blessed woman he is a feminist
he's the most
incredibly supportive man uh
and uh to everyone he's a motivator he
gets up every day raring to go
and he finds new things to do and
still reporting to this amazing album
for the whalers this year
and he's working on music constantly
makes my life as easy as he can
every moment and he's just a lovable guy
and very funny he makes me laugh every
day of my life he's really
an amazing guy i think um if there's a
way to like
subconsciously submerge ourselves in all
men's minds right now
i do believe a secret way into a woman's
heart
is humor a hundred percent yes
and a a daily kindness i think
it just goes the longest way and i know
that you're doing
the red table talks with your niece lily
and your daughter emily and when we come
back
i want to talk about this because i
am so excited for this for
all of us uh that
i just can't wait to dive in and when
you
are able to share the life journey
with other people so that other people
don't feel alone and we can benefit from
each other's wisdom and there's a
diversity within your family of
[Music]
experiences